Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier,
and welcome to Stick Shift!
Um...
I was heavily debating whether I should make a video about this game...
Uh, uh. For one reason; I'm trying to keep it together.
This game is about...
"Your...
'relationship' with your car."
is about the easiest way that I could say it.
So I'm gonna start it...
and you're gonna immediately see what I'm talking about.
Bear with me.
I'm trying to keep it together :)
Soo...
Start it...
(in-game car revs)
(funky music plays)
(giggling) and then... you literally... (containing laughter)
and then you jack off your car... :)
And shift (in-game car rev) into gears.
and it's called Stick Shift (containing gigglies)
Anyway...
uh, fine.
It's totally fine.
Don't worry about it!
It's a hundred percent fine! :)
'cause this is a fun game.
I-It might be moderately educa-
Oh, shit. God damn it. I didn't mean to do that. I apologize.
My bad.
Let's try again here...
Sorry.
I'm gonna crank my yank back up into gear (aggressively moves mouse)
There we go!
Let's shift at 'em.
Ooh, that's a good shift right there.
You gotta get it in sync with everything... else... (containing laughter)
uuhhh, here we go.
Hu- Aw!! I missed my gear.
Try it one more time.
I'm sorry.
I'm not good at this!
(distraught) I don't know why!
I'm not good at it!
I'm trying my buh-est.
Alright, we're gonna get this.
We're gonna get this...
Uh... this feels weird, but
Somehow enjoying myself-- alright,
Huh, hah, hah
C'mon-- AHH. There we go!
Now we've got it going into gear :D
Don't worry!
I got it!
Yeah!
Uh-huh.
Uh-ah!
WHOA!
Whoa, what is with your eyes, man?
What is with your eyes?!
Oh my God, where are you driving?
Why are you driving? (police siren in the background)
Oh boy!
AHH!
AWW
Oh no! :(
They got me!
NoOoOoO!
Let me try one more time, Officer.
Aw, game over, man.
Game over.
(police talking in the background)
(sniff) oh man...
What does that mean?
What does that mean?!
(in-game kiss noise)
Mu- what!?
(in-game kiss noise again)
What does that mean?
(barrage of kissing)
What am I doing?
(kissing noise continues)
Wh- Wh- Wha- What am-
Is that how long it's gonna be until I can play again?
Is that-
(kiss)
Oh my God.
Are you kidding me?
Oh my God, it is! That's how long I need to play-
That's how long it wants me to wait until I can play again?!
Oh, man. That's amazing!
Oh, but I'm gonna beat the system here.
Don't worry about me, I got this.
Don't worry!
(exhale)
Okay.
Alright.
So.
(laugh-cough) If this looks weird,
t- it's the same game!
Trust me! It's the same game.
Um.
What I had to do is I had to go to the website
and download a separate version of the game
that's bundled in this pack
with two other games
that are totally inappropriate for you guys to watch!!
Don't worry about it!
Not that Stick Shift... is appropriate.
But just bear with me on this one.
There's apparently an "updated, new and improved" version of the game that's gonna be... better.
I don't know how it's gonna be better but it's gonna be better.
(car rev) alright. Yep.
There we go.
Oh- that is- that is. That is. That is definitely better.
Yeah, I- The controls are just much more smooth.
Oh! His- the textures on his face are just-
Wait.
No, hang on.
Whoa! There we go.
That's what I was hoping for.
Now, we're gonna get to the bottom of this.
And we're gonna beat this game.
And I'm gonna shift correctly.
So, doooooon't worry about it.
I'm really whaling my mouse on this one.
I'mma flingin' it.
Hard and (laughter) fast.
Don't worry.
Alright, here we go.
Here we go!
Hya-
Oh God.
Why does that take so much?
AHH! There we go!
Oh, gotta get those headlights and demons inside you shooting out of your eyeballs so that you can-
pleasure your car
to maximum efficiency.
I mean, it's perfectly normal.
I'm renaming this Let's Play to
"How To Drive a Stick Shift."
because this is purely an educational video and there's NOTHING weird about it
in any capacity.
So you guys don't need to worry about a thing.
It's totally fine.
And...
HY-ah
(car screech) Oh! What!?
No!
Alright, here we go.
(car rev) Oh! (laughter)
That's the stuff...
Whoa!
Where are we going now?
Where are we going?
Uh, this guy is having a trip.
(police siren)
Uh oh.
(car screech) Aw! What!
No!
God damn it!
Aw! Fuckin...
Ugh
Goddamn it, I'm really trying here!
Aw, man...
(police talking in the background)
Aw, no.
Not again!
Okay, so I looked it up and apparently that -- the police pulling you over -- is one separate ending.
And if I hadn't've kissed my way to ten hours,
I would have been able to play it again on the first game that I downloaded.
So,
I've got about eight minutes left...
I'm gonna... I'm gonna try the other games.
What could happen?
What's the worst?
What's the worst that could happen?
(instant regret)
(dismissive) That looks promising.
(instant regret) Oh, God no.
No, God.
(crying laughter)
Oh, my God.
No thank you.
(Markiplier breaks down)
(cover your eyes, kids!)
Oh, man. Is this a game?!
Oh, God. Is that a corn dog or a popsicle?
Oh, geez.
Oh, my God.
NOPE.
No- Nuh, no. Nu-uh. Ain't doin' it. Nope.
Nope.
NOPE.
Okay.
Alright.
Woo.
Alright. Woo
Alright. Woo. Alright. WOOO. ALRIGHT.
WOOOOOOO.
Okay. (in-game phone buzz)
Oh, let me just... BOINK!
Oh, God. What are we doing?!
...okay.
Ah.
Oh, okay.
This is normal.
What are we doing? Why are we shaking hands?
Whooooaaaaaa-- okay.
OH GOD, NOOO.
Hazzah!
Okay, it's back.
I brushed my teeth because I'm healthy and I needed to wash my mouth.
That was supposed to sound like, you know, wash my dirty mouth out but...
just came across really weeeiiiirrrd, huh?
Okay. Anyway.
Alright. So apparently the endings are randomly generated, occasionally it'll just stop you with the other thing.
But, here we go!
(car revs)
Alright!!!!
Having a great time!
Playing a game.
Video games are fun, everybody.
Alright, here we go.
(grunt)
YEAAAHHH! Now we're talkin'.
Now hopefully no one's gonna stop this joy ride this time.
HOPEFULLY.
Something's gonna happen. I dunno what, but something's gonna happen.
(police siren)
NOOOOOO!
(screech) NOOOOOO!
Stop that! ;-;
Goddamn it, twice in row.
Mother humpin' humper fuck.
(SIGHING)
Am I gonna wait
to try again?
You goddamn fucking right I am.
Son of a bitch.
Okay, we're back for one more go
and at this point I'm pretty much an expert at this game,
so, don't worry as I expertly speed my way through this stick shifting mastery.
Let me show you how it's done
OOOOOOHHHHHH.
HEEEEEYYYY. Okay.
(police siren)
Oh, come on!
Oh, come on!!
What the fucking FUUUCKK!
Oh, this is the most BULLSHIT I've ever seen in mah life.
That's bullshit.
It knows it's bullshit.
Yeah, I'm gonna wait. Yeah, I'll wait. I'll fucking wait. Fuck it.
FUCK it.
One...
BINGO!!! Bongo.
Okay, apparently we're back. Alright, here we go again.
(car revs) HU PUH PUH PUH
Alright.
(engine revs)
(imitating the engine revving)
Okay...
(police siren)
Ohhh!! You gotta be kidding me!!
YOU'VE
GOT
TO BE
KIDDING ME.
YOU'VE
GOT
TO BE
KIDDING
MEEEEEEAAAEEEEEEEEE
Well.
That didn't work out for me.
For some reason, either I was doing something very wrong,
and I don't think I was ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
or...
random number generation was being very unkind to me.
I'm not sure which is which, but apparently it didn't want me to finish (oh ho)
...in more ways than one ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
but it didn't want me to finish the game, so
that's all I've got for now!
So, thank you everybody so much for watching.
And as always, I will see you
in the next video.
BY-
I'M BACK
It's another day
it's literally twenty-four hours after I've tried the first one
and I'm gonna try this again because
(inhale) I've got nothing but free time on my hands so let's try to jack off the car, why don't we?
(revving)
(funny voice) This is what I do for fun in my spare time!
So I looked it up, and there's actually is about a fifty percent chance between getting the cop ending and
the happy ending, if you know what I mean ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
So I've just been incredibly unlucky!
(laugh) Good for me!
That's not used to in my life...
(croak)
You've also may have noticed that I even got a different camera in the meantime.
IT'S BEEN THAT LONG!
Here we go!
Alright, it's big time now. I got headlight eyes and I'm swirling around,
I don't think it's a good idea that I'm just spinning my car in a donut in whatever street I'm going to,
but hey.
Here's to hoping that no cops are gonna show up.
WHOOOAAA
OOOH.
Okay, I can't cock this one up.
OOOH, I can't cock it up. It better not stall out, baby!
Here we go!
AAAAHHHH!!!!! (car revs)
OOOOOHHHH!!!! :D
YES
I went into warp drive!
I made the jump to hyper-space.
I'm doing it!
I'm jerking this car so GOOOOOOD! (look, this is really awkward to type.)
You know, there are certain things you never expect to exclaim at the top of your lungs,
so that your neighbors question you even more than they have in the past.
But I don't give a fuck!
I'm JERKING OFF MUH CAR!
Oh, hey.
I didn't even notice that.
Hey, six gear.
Am I ready to do that?
Do I have enough juice?
HYYAAAAHHH! (car revs)
YEEAAHHH!
I don't know what happened, but my sp-
Oh, God. I'm blacking out. I'm whitin' out. Oh geez.
Did I won? Did I finally won? Did I beat the odds?
E-eugh.
Oh, God. Eugh, ugh.
Eugh.
Why is that like that?
That is no good.
Ugh, God.
Why's it gotta drip,
but either way!
That's the end of Stick Shift.
A-and, the other inappropriate games I played.
Or perfectly appropriate!
I'm not gonna judge!
It's the frickin Internet.
It's a wasteland of porn and weird fetishes
so who am I to say that you can't love a car.
So,
Anyway,
I don't know what I'm trying to say here...
But either way, that's the end of this game and that's the end of this video.
So thank you everybody so much for watching,
let me know what you thought,
down in the comments below! OR DON'T.
Either way is good with me.
And as always,
I will see you in the next video.
BYE BYE!!!
(end music)
10/10 game. Would jerk again ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)